later today some top bosses will have
already made more money than the average
worker earns in a year most offices have
of course only just reopened for 2017
after the Christmas break but by
lunchtime the high pay center has said
many executives will pass the average
annual salary of 28,000 200 pounds it
means today has been nicknamed fat cat
Wednesday so in today's debate we're
asking our executives paid too much well
with us now to discuss this are the
Guardian columnist dawn Foster and
executive director at the Adam Smith
Institute Sam Bowman very good morning
to you both at dawn let me turn to you
first it does seem incredible doesn't it
people heading out to work this morning
barely back to the office or the shop or
the factory or whatever it might be and
already they're being told that others
have learnt more than them in a whole
year
it is incredible especially at the time
when a lot of people feel the pinch
after Christmas but I think it shows
that we do have a big problem with pay
inequality in the UK certain poverty
rates may be down but inequality is
wider than ever and I think measures
such as this that really show exactly
how how disparate it is really bring
that home to people and there were some
research a week ago that showed that the
link between high pay and performance is
completely negligible and actually in
the last 10 years executive pay is risen
by 80 percent but return on investment
has only risen by one percent so I think
there's a big big disparate kind of
problem there yeah let's turn to Sam now
Sam
it is pretty unpalatable isn't it for
people who are at the lower end of the
wage scale to hear that bosses are being
paid so much we know the government says
that it's going to do something about it
what's your thought well I think people
viewing with two questions the first is
are these people being overpaid and the
second is are they worse off because of
it and the answer to both is no we have
a lot of evidence that chief executives
when they're good can add a lot of value
to their firm much much more than
they're being paid
one example is Burberry which lost half
a billion in value when it's brilliant
CEO angler
step down suddenly a few years ago and
there are lots and lots of examples like
that the second question our workers
worse off because of this again is no
because workers do well when the firm's
they're working for too well and firms
more than ever now in a globalized world
need to have the best talent at the top
because the strategic decisions that
those CEOs make can have a huge effect
not just on whether the firm is
profitable or not but on the life or
death of the firm so if you're a worker
you want the best leaders in charge in
your firm so that you are globally
competitive and you're succeeding on a
global level I mean doesn't Sam have a
point dawn the fact that how much money
bankers are earning CEOs are earning
that always makes a headline for what
doesn't make the headlines is that if
the good work that good chief execs
actually do to help a company survive
but also the fact that some CEOs do the
work they're paid for should shouldn't
really be headline news what should be
headline news is the fact that for
instance care workers nurses etc do
incredible work day to day but they're
very very undervalued very very
underpaid and I think a lot of people in
Britain especially you know on the low
pay scale would argue that for instance
a nurse is what is worth more than the
chief executives they save lives every
day they work extraordinary hard why
should a chief executive be paid 14
times more than a nurse so I think it's
very very arbitrary in that respect and
I think you know today's measure showing
that chief executives have been paid by
mid day more than more than most of us
kind of shows that dawn isn't it down to
shareholders though to decide how much
the bosses should be made a shareholders
a happy if the company's making a lot of
money they're employing a lot of people
if they give me a lot of tax back to the
country then it's up to shareholders
it's not up to people like us to to
complain is it I think it is up to us
for instance Tesco and lots of other big
companies pay a lot of people in the
minimum wage and a lot of people then
struggle to get bides so they have to
turn to the government get housing
benefit get working Family Tax Credit so
actually if shareholders decide to pay
chief executives a lot but pay people at
bottom very little then it is actually
the taxpayers who in the end end up
paying for that so I think we are
actually subsidizing very high pay and
then and then in turn subsidizing very
low pay for companies
would you have to say to that I think it
to be honest completely misunderstands
how wages work it's certainly true that
nurses aren't paid as much as we'd like
them to but even if you took all of the
money that we pay all of the chief
executives in the country not just the
footsie 100 ones but all of them it
would be a drop in the ocean when it
comes to the wider wage bill of workers
in general now if you're a worker
working for a footsie 250 firm what you
want is to be working for a successful
firm the real problem we've had in the
last couple of years is that British
firms are struggling to compete on the
global level and one of the reasons for
that is that the strategic decisions
that they've made haven't always been
the best ones now we've seen that
there's a global trend towards paying
executives more the reason for that and
there's a lot of good evidence about
this and I'm happy to show it to dawn
later on there's a lot of good evidence
that CEOs have more and more on
importance to the value of their firms
because it's such a competitive world
that if you made the wrong decision
let's take the example of Samsung versus
sony Sony decided not to invest in smart
phones Samsung made a strategic decision
to to invest in smart phones Samsung is
much bigger than Sony now it's a huge
firm all because of that strategic
decision that they made so I think it's
really strange that people would be
surprised that a CEO should earn a
couple you know two hundred times more
three hundred times more than a basic
worker because it's so important to get
that one person at the top right and
it's so important to hire that top
talent that it's completely it's very
predictable that if firms would be
willing to pay top dollar to get this
top talent and I'm glad they do so how
do you feel then about the government
stepping in saying they're making it too
easy mazing she's making it one of her
top priorities to make sure she can
actually deal with this and pay gap
between the the less unfortunate and the
more fortunate and also looking at the
gender pay gap as what she says gonna
step in there to make sure that that gap
is also it's also important how do you
feel about that
I think rather than looking at the top
the government should be focusing on the
bottom and focus on what on what are the
things that are holding back the
earnings of people at the bottom now one
of those is growth we've had very very
poor economic growth over the past ten
years we all know that one of them is
the cost of living housing costs are
higher than ever childcare costs are
higher than ever and for a large part
it's because we're not building enough
houses
and we're not allowing enough child
carers to be in work because the sector
is so tightly regulated so I think it's
absolutely right that we should focus on
the wage gap but not by trying to drop
off the top of the earth at the top of
the wage gap we should be trying to
raise the bottom and really this kind of
view that all we need to do is lower the
earnings of people at the top is a very
very dangerous and very very
counterproductive way if we're actually
interested in helping the people at the
bottom door briefly final thoughts it's
very rare for me to agree to his may but
I think it shows that most people in
Britain and most people on the political
spectrum agree that we need more
inequality in pay and that includes
chief executives and people at the very
bottom okay I appreciate your time thank
you both very much Don Foster from The
Guardian Sam Bowman from the Adam Smith
to show you something very interesting
no doubt but yeah